they'll be taking on the southpaw cole
irvine as we just mentioned
and i think you're watching this young
man evolve right before our very eyes
just taking his game to another level as
far as pitching is concerned
right on the outside corner perfect
pitch by cole irwin and he strikes out
marcus simeon
to open up the ball game well the pace
is exactly what we talked about off the
top
not a change up here a little backdoor
slider they wanted this thing
down and in two and two the outfielder's
room in left center
and the delivery by irvin and that swung
out of this that was a fastball by of 93
and what a start to the game for cole
irvine a one two three top of the first
with two strikeouts with the is coming
up in the bottom half
has made only one appearance this season
has anthony kaye
but he has stayed stretched out at the
alternate site for these types of
opportunities when the jays need a spot
starter
and look at the run on that pitch in
under the hands of l'oreal as he swings
over the top of it two down
may the fourth be with you that's right
grounded to the right side biggio spins
his throw
he's not going to be in time and murphy
got himself a base hit
don't sleep on the murph speed where he
could smell it kite
here's the fish to chapman whistled into
center for a base hit
however to fail the ball is gritching
the second base up gabe morales had to
scramble out of the way murphy goes to
second
first and second and nobody out and
lowry is coming up
murphy's second champion at first ready
turns and delivers and jetta lined right
on the right field line that's going to
get down to base hit
into the corner rolling to the wall
murphy is scored chapman streaking
around third
comes to the plate there's no throw on
him as lowry doubles down the right
field line scoring two and the a's take
a two nothing lead
his ninth double of the year already
and two nothing a's in the bottom of the
second
doubled in the second ending last night
to bring home the first run
doubled again in the sixth inning last
night and almost had another double in
his lasted bat that was caught at the
center field wall
great thing about this play matt chapman
read it perfectly
and he was right behind murphy so still
nobody out two runs in here's moreland
this one's hit well left field toward
the corner guria going back
guerrilla turning around and that baby's
gone
even with the wind knocking it down by
12 feet dallas doesn't matter
moreland hooks it around the left field
foul pole
well this is what you call country
strong kite 95 mile an hour fastball
up and out and mitchy
oh buddy that's what a diet of steak and
potatoes will get you
and if it ain't steak and potatoes on
the menu it's oppo tacos
pack your bags type you know where we're
going all aboard
next top pound town a great teammate
um but he would have his portable space
heater
swing and a miss irving takes care of
his third strikeout
look what it is a change piece on its
best behavior
located in a perfect spot down and away
appetizing to buchet but the bottom just
falls out
[Music]
sweet and missy struck him out cole
irvin
is rolling man he's retired eight in a
row
so bottom of the fifth coming up the a's
four and the blue jays
you don't want to throw it inside and
have it cut over the middle of the plate
that goes right to the barrel you want
to start it on the barrel and then have
it cut
off the end of the back
runners go again 3-2 swing and a miss
thornton gets him
to strand a couple of runners and to
five and the a still leading the blue
jays four to nothing
one down and santiago espinal lines one
into left field
for a one-out single the second hit of
the game for the blue jays
well you watch this kid play and
the more you watch him the more that he
impresses you
his numbers do not include the five
shutout innings tonight swinging him in
struck him out
that's number five
well they dropped that change up on him
down and in
to get to two strikes
[Applause]
run a heater up there back it up with
another one up top and
so two down and back around to the top
of the order now marcus simeon coming up
for the third time
simeon has struck out and grounded out
tonight runner will be on the move on
the pitch
there goes espino the 3-2 another
change-up and this ball is well hit
left center field it's down and up
against the wall on a bounce
espional around third digging for home
there will not be a throw
and simeon with an rbi double to get the
blue jays on the board
simeon comes back to the coliseum and
delivers the blue jays first run with a
double to left center
a good hitter is going to start looking
for it this one
is up and marcus has talked about
those first hundred at bats of this
season trying to get his timing down
you get the timing on the fastball first
and then the breaking ball is going to
come after
at that time he timed up that change up
short hop the wall in left field
i mean he's back home you mentioned his
family's here but this is familiar
surroundings right here he's done this
a few times in his career
[Applause]
[Music]
got it on the inside corner so
big strikeout for irvin a run for
toronto
bottom of the six coming up it's four to
one another two strike pitch
and that's on the inside corner man oh
man he's
dotting the black there and guerrero
thought it might have been inside he
wanted to say something
instead he quickly jogs away from home
plate
a little pop-up behind first and olson
had it all the way and i really think he
did have it all the way oh there's no
question and that's why
jed lowry is laughing
strike three call right on the inside
corner and that indeed caught the corner
eight strikeouts for cole irvine in
seven innings
and i would love nothing more than to
get that swing and miss
punch out come off the bump to an
ovation
and a miss he struck him now with 94
miles an hour
sensational performance tonight by cole
irvin
and he will get a standing ovation as he
walks off the mound tall and proud
as he should be bottom of the eight
coming up
four one eight
trying
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hustling in and he's got it and that's
the ball game